A prophetic dream that changes
everything we knew about "Game
of Thrones!" And it happens in the very
first episode of "House of the Dragon."
It's no secret that Game of Thrones Season 8
received an astounding amount of backlash from
fans and critics alike, but the most
baffling element of the entire season
might be the fact that the series finale left so
many questions unanswered. One of the most obvious
examples of this is the mysterious backstory
of the White Walkers, a group of demonic ice
creatures who invade Westeros from the far north
with an army of the undead. These beings may have
extinguished life across the entire continent,
were it not for the Battle of Winterfell.
The threat of the White Walkers ends with the
death of the Night King at the hands of Arya
Stark. Afterwards, the series protagonists set
their sights on King's Landing and the threat
of Cersei Lannister, and the White Walkers
are barely even mentioned. As such, we never
receive any concrete answers about who the White
Walkers really are, or what their purpose is.
One of the most mysterious aspects
of the White Walkers is their strange
connection to the dragon-riding Targaryen
family. Both factions are integral to the
ancient prophecy involving Azor Ahai, often
known as "the prince that was promised."
Now, it seems possible that we might actually gain
some concrete information about this relationship,
as HBO's House of the Dragon has already answered
a huge question Game of Thrones left in its wake.
One major mystery at the heart of Game of Thrones,
as well as the books on which it was based, is the
motive behind Aegon the Conqueror's invasion of
Westeros. George R.R. Martin's Fire & Blood claims
that Aegon only invaded the continent after being
insulted by the Storm King Argilac Durrandon ,
and that his abrupt call to arms was precipitated
by his own belief that the Seven Kingdoms of
Westeros ought to be united into one nation.
However, Episode 1 of House of the
Dragon, "The Heirs of the Dragon,"
reveals that this isn't actually true, and
finally gives fans a definitive answer for
why Aegon decided to conquer Westeros in
the first place. King Viserys tells his heir
Rhaenyra Targaryen that Aegon the Conqueror had
a prophetic dream of the White Walker invasion.
This awful vision inspired him to invade
Westeros as a way to save mankind from
destruction. Standing beside the skull of
Aegon's dragon, Balerion, Viserys says:
"Aegon saw absolute darkness
riding on those winds,
and whatever dwells within will
destroy the world of the living."
Viserys goes on to say that Aegon called his
dream "the Song of Ice and Fire," and that
the only way for mankind to survive this wintry
threat is with a Targaryen on the Iron Throne.
This revelation changes everything we thought
we knew about the history of House Targaryen,
as well as their relationship
to the mysterious White Walkers.
House of the Dragon essentially reveals
that the Targaryen dynasty was established
to protect men from extinction, not out of Aegon
the Conqueror's desire for control and plunder.
This reveal also establishes that the fates of
the White Walkers and the Targaryens have been
intertwined for centuries, providing more concrete
understanding of why the Targaryen lineage is
wrapped up in the legend of Azor Ahai, a legendary
hero prophesied to save the world. Furthermore,
"The Heirs of the Dragon" makes it clear that
this secret has been passed down through each
Targaryen generation, from one ruler to the next.
Considering the fact that this knowledge appears
to have been lost by the time the events of Game
of Thrones come around, it will be interesting to
see what becomes of this particular plot
point as House of the Dragon continues.
No matter what happens, it's remarkable that
House of the Dragon has already managed to
clear up one of the many mysteries
left unresolved by Game of Thrones.